RFK Jr's been making the rounds we
showed you a couple Clips yesterday of
him with Bill Maher
I want to show you one more right now
this is the two of them talking about
the biased slanderous coverage of RFK Jr
and his campaign that the media has been
dumping all over him over the last
couple weeks okay where's my next I
think what's my next no you know what
okay I just want to say I'm I'm doing
this for a reason one because I think
they deserved richly to be mocked for
that for that attitude I just do not
like the attitude and this gets back to
what you said when you first sat down
there like Liberals are different than
we were kids these are not our
grandfather's liberals you know I I
think Liberals are still liberals but
whatever for whatever reason woke became
the word I know it's not always blah
blah blah but that's the word people use
now for left gone too far and left just
changed their attitude in very in a lot
of ways they're the opposite of liberals
I mean liberalism was about let's have a
colorblind Society
okay so what they were covering there
and why Bill had the newspapers they
were going through some of the stories
that they've been hitting RFK on and
what nonsense it is and how it's coming
out of the purported liberal side and of
course yes bill is Right wok and liberal
have nothing to do with each other and
you guys get all of that stuff so Bill I
love you but I gotta nudge you a little
bit here this is why just call yourself
a liberal at this point when the ship
has sailed an RFK is dealing with the
same version of all of that it's the
liberals who now censor it's the
liberals who don't let you question
science it's the liberals who want
mandates and all of that stuff okay you
get it now let's go to a headline uh
from Newsweek uh related to this Hotes
guy and what happened here doctor that
Joe Rogan challenged to debate calls RFK
Jr shirtless Putin so Hotes is going
after RFK Jr check out this picture of
RFK Jr because this is the picture they
were going after so this is just a
couple days ago I think this is at his
house somewhere in Southern Cali and RFK
Junior who is 70 years old look at
looking pretty Putin like pretty jacked
right there uh there's a lot of
questions people are saying okay he must
be taking testosterone or something else
or whatever I think that's besides the
point uh you know the guy obviously is
doing something seemingly for his health
and even if he looked like even if
he looked like this hottest guy who
doesn't look so great that is somewhat
irrelevant to whether the facts that
you're talking about and the way you
analyze the data and the stats and the
numbers on Cove it is legit
or not right
[Music]